c'est pas un pitbull je crois c'est
incroyable ça et c'est vrai que moi
Daniel je peux comprendre
je trouve que la loi sur les parce que
c'est pas moi qui ai fait la loi moi
j'ai peur c'est raisonné d'accord mais
il y a une loi contre les chiens
dangereux il faut les musées c'est une
des lois qui est la moins respectée au
monde quoi je vois des des vélaires des
en liberté dans presque dans des Square
pour enfants et comme les gens n'ont pas
peur malheureusement bon je sais que la
peur n'est pas de danger mais il
faudrait que cette fois soit respectueux
c'est pas respecté c'est une arme par
destination
comme ça il faut expliquer que les
pitbulls donc sont classées en catégorie
1 interdit à l'importation la
reproduction donc on a pas le droit d'en
avoir ils doivent être stérilisés pour
les femelles et castrer pour les mâles
donc c'est incroyable non seulement
qu'il y en ait mais que il puisse se
balader sans muselière ce sont des
animaux dangereux parce que c'est la
faute c'est la faute des maîtres avant
tout pardon c'est la faute
méchants et là c'est une image qui fait
énormément de peine évidemment mais
pardon les premiers fautifs ce sont les
maîtres et je pense que ces chiens là il
faut pas les les tuer classiquement il
faut les isoler il faut s'en occuper et
je ne vois pas pour comprendre cette
sanction de peine de mort immédiate à
chaque fois pour les chiens alors qu'on
ne la prend pas pour les hommes qui eux
tuent en connaissance de cause le chien
il sait pas qui va tuer ou qui va
amputer quelqu'un
juste par contre Guillaume qu'est-ce
qu'on va en faire du chien c'est à dire
que moi par contre un chien qui fait ça
même si j'aime les chiens plus que tout
je suis désolé là le chien pour le coup
pour moi il faut le piquer
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire déjà tu prends les précautions tu
le mets une muselière et ça c'est la
première fois maintenant moi j'ai eu un
chien qui mordait maintenant bah de quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant
déjà tu le mets dans un cadre plus
propice
à quelqu'un et il peut il peut agresser
il y a un enfant de 5 ans qui passe
j'ai été dans ce cas là j'ai pas tué mon
chat
comme ça ton chien
non mais il aurait pu mais il aurait pu
mais ça sortait jamais sans muselière je
l'enferme et tout ça
en fait quand on adopté c'est quoi alors
je vais vous dire moi quand j'ai adopté
mon premier rottweiler je savais pas
qu'elle allait être méchante elle était
méchante et ça on a beau dire
l'éducation etc on ne peut rien faire
alors tu vois que ça peut pas mais c'est
comme regarde Quentin un enfant pardon
mais quand tu as un enfant a problème
qui est extrêmement violent tu vas pas
t'en tu appelles l'abandonner tu vas pas
t'en séparer mais voilà le chien qui m'a
quand tu la donnes c'est pour la vie et
je suis désolé que j'ai fait moi ce que
j'ai fait je n'ai jamais sorti son musée
d'air j'ai déménagé exprès dans une
maison j'ai mis des clôtures partout et
il y a jamais eu de problème majeur
hyper vigilant et tu aimes ton chien
donc voilà tu t'en es occupé là c'est
pas c'est des types qui prennent ou des
des des gens qui prennent des chiens qui
n'ont rien à [__] c'est pour qu'il est
l'heure comment
déplie du bon sens
pour être agressifs etc et en plus les
pitbull c'est une espèce de race un peu
croisé non mais pitbull je parlais des
pitbulls la petite boule c'est une race
un peu croisé et cetera donc il y a une
dégénérescence alors que l'American
staff qui est autorisé est un chien de
race voilà qui est un chat très gentil
c'est bien élevé non mais c'est la
vérité c'est vrai mais oui